allora in realtà non so bene come
iniziare questo video vi dico la verità
solo che
ultimamente mi sento un po triste se
proprio dobbiamo dirla
tutta e quindi
non ce la faccio più forte di me non
riesco a piedi per il culo così era una
cazzata ovviamente bene a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovissimo
video io sono falli j questo è il mio
canale da una vita e mezza
morente no in realtà adesso vi spiego un
po le mie considerazioni a riguardo che
le views del mio canale sono calate
rispetto a come erano un tempo una volta
quando ho iniziato c'erano pochi
contenuti ognuno si andava a cercare
propri canali per guardarli oggi tutti i
contenuti del web la maggior parte
arrivano in faccia agli spettatori ok
quindi non è più il creator che attira
mai contenuto che fai creato lo che è
questa cosa è cambiata nel tempo questo
rende soprattutto chi fa questo lavoro
da un sacco di tempo molto meno
performante rispetto a un tempo perché
oggi c'è tutto sul web che tutto poi ti
su tik tok fa video mia cugina e fa 8
milioni di visualizzazioni tik tok chi
li ferma più quindi non è neanche ormai
il concetto di views chiaramente non
esiste quasi più cioè non è che non
esiste più ma se uno se un creato rimane
attaccato al concetto di views fa una
vita di merda e dobbiamo farci una
ragione di questo perché ormai il web si
evolve e domani non sapremmo neanche
come sarà visto che zuckerberg ha creato
meta verso dove
andremo tutti a viver tipo il matrix e
quindi cosa può fare un creator
per ovviare a questo problema fare
quello che gli piace punto quando ho
iniziato a fare video tutti hanno
iniziato a seguirmi subito ed è stata
una fortuna e poi sono stato bravo anche
io a saper cavalcare questo cavallo che
va velocissimo quindi se mi aveste
chiesto quanto secondo te puoi durare
così io avrei risposto 34 anni ok ne
sono passati dieci quindi dopo dieci
anni tutto è iniziato a calare io questa
cosa a me l'aspettavo dal giorno 1
quindi dal giorno 1
io ho fatto un paio di cose ho messo
tutto da parte cioè non sono uno
spendaccione a quello perché sono io
così di indole ma numero due la cosa che
cala e l'attenzione che il pubblico
verso di te e questo problema che non si
pone ma non si poteva neanche ai tempi
perché io di carattere detesto la fama
cioè più una persona è conosciuta e meno
io la invidio questo da sempre ne perché
io sono una persona molto timida anche
se non si direbbe molto riservata più
che timida perché nel tempo poi sono
migliorato però comunque sia a me non
piace stare sotto i riflettori ok quindi
il fatto di perdere questa cosa è un
plus quindi o da tutta questa situazione
in realtà è un plus continua a fare il
mio lavoro che comunque è il mio lavoro
ce n'è adesso stiamo parlando come se
non si fa cenno niente ma comunque
rimane il mio lavoro sarei un pazzo a
fermarmi perché comunque faccio lo
stesso numeri e qui arriviamo al momento
cruciale del video qual è la chiave di
tutto questo fare quello che ci piace se
è un creator fa quello che gli piace non
è mai mai sconfitto ma perché circa nel
2017 adesso non mi ricordo popola il
batter royale
quello che inizia con la effe non so se
avete presente quel giorno è iniziato un
po quel quel periodo in cui dipende che
cosa porti non dipende chi sei e io ho
detto no
ho detto no perché non volevo portare un
qualcosa che non mi facesse divertire
una volta seduto qua davanti ok a
discapito delle views qui da quel
momento la il mio canale pian piano ha
iniziato ad andare un po giù
perché poi sono subentrate altre cose
che avrei dovuto portare che non ho
portato ogni continuato a fare sempre
quello che volevo fare ok e sono
contento di questo sono molto contento
perché io ho fatto questa scelta con
cognizione cioè io non è che l'ho fatta
perché sono stato costretto a farla l'ho
voluta fare e oggi sono contento perché
se oggi va clash royale ma a me clash
royale fa cagare io crash royale non lo
porto e non me ne frega niente di fare
centinaia di migliaia di chiusi in meno
di quello che potrei fare non importa
non me ne frega più dell'attenzione ne
ho già avuto più di quanto mi sarei mai
potuto immaginare più di di pai quindi
quando un utente medio e non lo sa
scrive poi se mi dispiace che a me
dispiace che a te e di spiaggia perché a
me non dispiace quello che voglio
cercare di fare io adesso e vivere la
mia vita nel modo più libero possibile
questa è la mia felicità e credo che ci
sto anche riuscendo quindi oggi io sono
nettamente più felice di prima perché
prima avevo prima e mi divertivo a fare
quello che facevo e non è che detto così
sembra che stavo facendo cose per
performare no io prima mi divertivo ma
comunque avevo l'ansia del fatto che
quando tu hai tanti numeri comunque hai
tante ansie perché è normale perché devi
tenere alto alta l'asticella tutte
queste cose qua no quindi mi sento senza
quel peso e riesco a godermi anche di
più le cose quindi oggi non ti
dispiacere
anzi intanto è tutto questo argomento io
sto facendo per le views cioè non per il
mio personaggio perché comunque il
personaggio fa vj ormai affermatissimo
nel senso che per strada continua a
fermarmi chiunque continuano a propormi
lavori tante persone perché sanno come
lavoro sono contento di questo perché
insomma vuol dire che lavoro anche bene
quindi sono contento ma vabbè che loro
dicono loro non posso dire io di me
stesso quindi io lavorativamente sono a
posto io devo solo viverlo come voglio
io quindi libero e felice punto quindi e
questa è la verità non sono le une cui
non sono quei numeri qua sotto che fanno
non so anche quanto farò sto video anzi
vi dico la verità probabilmente farà
molto di più di un video normale
probabimente fra centinaia di migliaia
forse un milione non lo so non me ne
frega un cazzo questo è un video che
volevo fare da un po ma non l'avevo
fatto finora perché non avevo appunto
voglia di farlo ma ora che voglia lo
faccio proprio perché non ha un timing
so che l'hanno fatto anche altre persone
tra cui step nilo visto recentemente
ulivisti la tela di un occhiata perché
più o meno dice le stesse cose
e aver fatto parte della vita di così
tante persone quindi il fatto che un
sacco di persone ormai mi riconoscano
perché ho portato della felicità detta
in modo bruttissimo ma passatemi il
termine nelle loro vite quando magari
erano più piccoli adesso ancora persone
che non mi hanno visto e non mi
conoscono la mi conosceranno e avranno
questa sensazione su di me
per me è tutto e tutto figo e tutto
giusto è il mio obiettivo non è stato
raggiunto è stato sfondato di testa con
camion ai 3.000 allora quindi nice a
proposito di cose che mi piacciono mi
piace molto parlare al microfono e dirvi
che cosa ne penso su determinate cose
quindi i prossimi video nelle prossime
settimane saranno tutti degli argomenti
che vorrei trattare con voi e sapere che
cosa ne pensate anche voi nei commenti
ci vediamo con i prossimi video che
saranno non gameplay ma voglio fare
questa cosa perché adesso che il
microfono davanti ai sfruttiamo questo
questo questo appare di ferro vecchio
metallico per qualcosa quindi facciamo
un po di talking come sempre se vi è
piaciuto lasciato commento mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale e noi come sempre
quante volte ho detto come sempre ci
rivediamo a un prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]